summer of revolution documentaire
réalisé par Anne Richard que la conçu et
écrit avec Annette Lévy Villard cette
militante du MLF de la première heure
dont nous venons de vivre le voyage
initiatique vécu au début des années 70
aux États-Unis pour rejoindre et
s'inspirer du combat féministe des
sisters américaines de woman sleep son
rêve d’alors se libérer pour devenir un
homme comme les autres Simone de
Beauvoir était passé par l'armée en
étant toujours là aujourd'hui ou le
combat pour l'égalité des droits entre
les femmes et les hommes est-il passé à
un autre chapitre nous allons en
débattre avec nos invités présentes
maintenant sur ce plateau de débadoc
comme promis Annette Lévy Villars est
avec nous bienvenue on en sait déjà un
peu plus sur vous après avoir vu ce film
sur votre engagement féministe avec le
mouvement de libération des femmes après
ce film donc réalisé par Anne Richard
vous êtes réalisatrice de documentaires
ancienne journal juste la libération
auteur romancière avec notamment cet
ouvrage chronique du nom de choc Mitou
secoue la planète publié aux éditions de
l'Observatoire dont vous avez ensuite
tiré d'ailleurs un documentaire un autre
documentaire mais toujours réalisé avec
un Richard une Roselyne Bachelot est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
ancienne ministre votre dernier
portefeuille sous le quinquennat
précédent était celui de la culture
c'était entre juillet 2020 et mai 2022
vous êtes également ancienne député RPR
puis
UMP puis en octobre
1995 vous étiez entre autres à l'origine
et rapporteur général de l'Observatoire
à l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes auprès de Gisèle Halimi qui était
plutôt Gisèle à la limite était auprès
de moi dans l'occurrence puisque c'est
vous qui avez eu l'idée ce conseil
d'ailleurs ce conseil s'appelle
aujourd'hui le Haut Conseil à l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes et il a
rendu on le verra tout à l'heure un
rapport assez alarmiste sur la situation
faites aux femmes aujourd'hui encore
dans notre pays vous êtes aussi l'auteur
Roselyne Bachelot de 682 jours c'est
évidemment le nombre de jours vous avez
passé à la tête de ce ministère de la
Culture et c'est un ouvrage sans phare
d'ailleurs qui ressemble bien à du
Roselyne Bachelot qu'on peut trouver
chez plomb c'est 11e bébé il est
semblable aux autres Sandrine Rousseau
est également avec nous bienvenue vous
êtes député Europe Écologie Les Verts de
Paris et l'une des figures de proue à la
fois politique et médiatique du
féminisme aujourd'hui vous êtes
fondatrice de l'association en parler
qui est une association d'entraide et
d'accompagnement de victimes de
violences sexuelles votre dernier
ouvrage s'intitule lui par-delà
l'androzen publiée aux éditions du Seuil
androssay néologisme qui remplace
anthropocène pour lier système
patriarcal capitalisme et dérèglement
climatique merci à toutes les trois
d'être là merci à vous tout
particulièrement parce que c'est
évidemment votre histoire une partie de
votre histoire et pas n'importe laquelle
qui racontait dans dans ce film en tout
cas moi ce que j'ai perçu senti à
travers ce film c'est qu'il témoignait
de de vos de vos doutes et de votre
cheminement intellectuel avec franchise
lorsque vous êtes parti aux États-Unis
avec des questions que vous soulevez
d'ailleurs dans ce documentaire comme
celle-ci faut-il cesser de coucher avec
l'ennemi sous-entendu bien sûr les
hommes ou comment réinventer l'amour ou
encore le polyamour est-il la solution
pour réconcilier hétérosexualité et
émancipation du patriarcat au final avec
toutes ces interrogations que vous avez
eu durant ce road trip vous en êtes
arrivé à laquelle conclusion concernant
que devait être l'émancipation féminine
à votre époque à votre tour des
États-Unis pour
combat avec les hommes aussi que
aujourd'hui qu'on était à l'époque à
l'époque on était vraiment dans la
révolte pure et dure c'est-à-dire faut
couper avec l'ennemi même si on était
toujours avec l'ennemi parce que les
hétérosexuels couchaient toujours avec
leurs frêne ou leur mari etc mais nous
on était on est pour commencer à parler
il faut couper avec le monde des hommes
après quand on a réussi à parler on
s'est rendu compte qu'on pouvait parler
et lutter aussi avec les hommes qu'on
ait plus besoin de de s'isoler comme ça
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui le débat
sur la non-mixité me paraît
particulièrement stupide parce qu'on en
est plus là c'est des on est on est
passé on a dépassé cette étape de il
faut qu'on s'entre nous parce qu'on peut
pas parler ça c'est fini à mon avis
Roselyne Bachelot j'ai trouvé cette
interview dans elle un bout d'interview
vous concernant et vous disiez je ne
suis pas différentialiste on m'a dit
vous n'y étiez pas pour différencier les
deux sectes plus que dire que les femmes
sont par nature différente nous a
cantonnés à des sujets dit féminins mais
je remarque je remarque que les femmes
ont une vision de la vie différente de
celle des hommes une autre appréhension
des sujets et c'est toujours bénéfique
pour la démocratie d'introduire d'autres
points de vue est-ce que vous avez
changé d'avis depuis cet interview ou ce
que ça reste une ligne de conduite
lorsqu'on parle de
l'égalité des droits entre les hommes et
les femmes aujourd'hui une personne qui
a comme moi quarante années de vie
politique
j'ai mené ma première campagne après
presque 45 ans même a toujours été en
fait en torsion sur ce sujet entre un
certain nombre de combats que nous avons
menés en faisant chanter si l'on peut
dire des qualités de proximité de
réalisme qui ont justifié qu'on ne vous
conseille du bout des mains ou du bout
des lèvres un certain nombre de
responsabilités qu'on a prises et puis
le fait qu'effectivement
cette vision différencialiste nous
amenaient à ne pas nous confier
l'urbanisme l'économie les finances les
postes de gestion prestigieux alors
j'avoue que quelques fois je me suis
saisi
lâchement de cette vision des prétendus
qualité féminines parce que j'ai
rencontré des femmes heureusement très
ambitieux et
qui n'était pas du tout proche des
réalités et à contrario des hommes qui
l'était mais je me suis assez lâchement
saisie de cette notion pour pousser mes
pions et arriver à amener des politiques
des politiques égalitaires j'avoue
toujours mes fautes qui sont nombreuses
pas différencialistes entre hommes et
femmes là-dessus les choses sont claires
selon vous les choses doivent nous être
ouvertes
évidemment de façon de façon claire
alors j'ai mené des politiques
évidemment volontaristes je vous citer
dans votre propos intro l'Observatoire
de la parité que j'ai que j'ai dirigé
j'ai mené les travaux sur cette loi
paritaire c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs je m'étais opposé au quota
tel que on les on les essayait de les
promouvoir au départ d'estimer que
c'était une avancée mais tout de suite
avec Gisèle à la limite on nous avait
nous sommes allés voir les trois
protagonistes des élections
présidentielles de 95 en l'occurrence
Lionel Jospin Edouard Balladur et
Jacques Chirac tout de suite nous avons
mis en avant la parité que le seul quota
imaginable c'était pas un quota c'était
du 55 ans
rebondir ce que vient de dire
Roselyne on a quand même avancé de façon
phénoménale vous avez effectivement une
femme qui peut être ministre des Armées
la parité a quand même très bien marché
en politique malgré tout il y a des
choses avancer je dis pas qu'on est
arrivé à l'égalité on en avait pas
encore là mais en quelques décades
parlant depuis 1970 ça fait des bons en
avant fabuleux en français ailleurs
alors on va voir ce qu'on pense il m'a
frappé dans le documentaire c'est à quel
point finalement on pourrait avoir les
mêmes slogans aujourd'hui dans les
mouvements féministes actuels et du coup
je suis moins optimiste que vous sur le
fait que nous ayons massivement avancé
[Rires]
par Suzanne faloudi et en fait moi j'ai
vraiment été frappé de ça c'est à dire
que finalement on a les mêmes
même les mêmes sous-groupes au sein du
féminisme j'ai envie de dire sur le la
reconnaissance d'une lesbianisme
politique comme étant aussi un acte
politique le la non-mixité la relation
hétérosexuelle la domination dans cette
relation hétérosexuelle etc et en fait
la fusion les luttes par exemple là dans
les retraites on le voit bien la
question des luttes quelle est la lutte
principale par rapport aux autres à
l'époque c'était pas
système de discussion la révolution
d'abord ou après voilà donc c'est en
cela que je me suis dit que oui nous
avantion parce qu'à chaque fois on fait
deux pas on recule d'un mais ça n'est
pas aussi rapide qu'on le pense et il y
a un passage de votre documentaire qui
m'a particulièrement intéressé qui était
la question du travail domestique et de
la répartition des tâches et si on
regarde les chiffres depuis les années
70 donc date à laquelle fait référence
documentaire et bien les hommes ont
progressé de 14 minutes par semaine ce
qui n'est on en conviendra pas une
révolution en termes de partage des
tâches domestiques donc on voit bien
qu'en fait il y a pas eu une révolution
dans la domination structurelle
qu'exercer les hommes sur les femmes par
contre il y a eu des avancées dans cette
dans vers cette égalité mais qui reste
des espèces de coin dans la domination
mais qui n'a pas encore été
la résistance la zone grise qui reste
par rapport aux documentaire qui raconte
les années 70
si la zone privée qui a pris du retard
vous avez quand même l'égalité comme
inscrite dans la loi la parité pas
simplement en France ailleurs aussi le
droit à la contraception le droit de
l'avortement etc etc mais
c'est là pour ça oui tout au débarque
tardivement c'est tout ce qui est
effectivement le travail domestique la
question de la violence dans dans des
relations entre les hommes et les femmes
c'est ça tout ça n'avait pas été
vraiment abordé on avait parlé des
infrastructures plutôt que de la vie
et obtenir l'IVG libre aujourd'hui on
est tranquille oui mais aujourd'hui on
est à l'hôpital non non mais aujourd'hui
on est à mettre le clitoris comme un
comme un objet politique ça ira le même
dans le débat politique et ça renvoie
évidemment au plaisir des femmes donc au
fait de jouir sans entrave mais sans
domination aussi et par ailleurs on en
est à discuter de l'inscription de l'IVG
dans la Constitution pourquoi parce
qu'aux États-Unis il est mis en danger
ce droit à l'IVG donc en fait je trouve
que voilà on est dans une espèce de
retour enfin on est en tous les cas dans
une résonance avec ce qui s'est passé
dans les années 70 moi en regardant ce
film qui est évidemment daté qui est une
borne je l'ai dit moi ce qui m'a frappé
quand même c'est que le combat social
est encore trop peu présent à ce
moment-là
la situation des femmes les plus les
plus modestes et est encore trop peu
abordé tout ce qui est tout ce qu'on a
baptisé sous le thème le terme
d'intersectionnalité est aussi absent
moi ça m'a frappé en étant
responsabilité au ministère de la
Culture évidemment on s'intéresse à ce
qui a été fait avant vous quand on fait
le bilan depuis le début de la cinquième
République depuis la création du
ministère de de la culture on voit que
les questions par exemple de violence
qui sont pratiquement consubstantielles
à l'éducation dans le dans le monde dans
le monde artistique dans le monde de là
où il y a des violences sexistes
sexuelles des violences de harcèlement
qui sont extrêmement présentes et qu'on
revendique même comme un fait culturel
c'est comme ça qu'on apprend tel métier
artistique et bien c'est combats étaient
y compris dans les années 80 absolument
absent on en parlait pas on en parle
seulement depuis depuis quelques années
et ça apparaît les nominations je suis
désolé en 80 quel nomination ont été
faites à la tête des grands
établissements culturels c'est très
simple le chiffre est clair c'est zéro
zéro donc on voit que
les combats sont encore très violents à
mener et que d'ailleurs à certains
nombre de vaches sacrées du monde
culturel pardonnez-moi de parler de
cette dernière expérience politique
qu'un certain nombre de vaches sacrées
on se demande parfois si elles ont leur
place si on met ce critère de façon
forte dans dans les décisions
répondre bien sûr non la question que je
me posais c'était de savoir s'il y avait
pas un besoin aujourd'hui pour les
féministes aujourd'hui
les associations féministes les
femmes qui mènent ce combat d'un retour
aux sources je m'explique par exemple
dans votre documentaire il était
question de pas se raser les gens il
était question de ne plus porter de
soutien-gorge or ce sont des réflexes
qui aujourd'hui les nouvelles féministes
et ce qu'il y a pas un besoin
aujourd'hui du côté des nouvelles
familles des nouvelles associations
féministes les retours aux sources je ne
sais pas parce que parce que certaines
féministes radicales dans votre document
et ça va ça vous a surpris d'ailleurs
laissez pousser avait décidé de laisser
pousser
de soutien c'est des symboles de de
symboles de libération qui apparaissait
à l'époque et vous lui avez constaté aux
États-Unis chez certaines
militantes féministes or je vois qu'il
ces symboles réapparaissent aujourd'hui
auprès des des plus jeunes femmes qui
militent aussi en faveur
du ML reviennent de même que et c'est en
cela qu'il y a une espèce de chaîne
invisible mais je voudrais revenir quand
même sur cette idée que dans le privé on
n'a pas gagné ou dans le public on a
gagné l'Assemblée nationale reste par
exemple un lieu extrêmement sexiste
aujourd'hui enfin je veux dire vraiment
vraiment quoi et sans sans beaucoup plus
de modération ou de vernis que à mon
avis du temps de Gisèle Halimi donc en
fait il y a quand même un sujet autour
des lieux de pouvoir qui n'ont pas été
massivement féminisées et la parité n'a
pas permis la parité à l'Assemblée
nationale nous ne sommes pas aujourd'hui
50% à l'Assemblée nationale donc une
nombreuses qu'avant on est plus
nombreuses et c'est en cela qu'il y a
une entrée dans un parlement avec 5
%, 3% c'est le nom de la proportion de
femmes élues député en 2022 c'était un
peu mieux d'ailleurs en 2017 c'était
38,7 mais ce n'est pas effectivement la
parité et et on voit bien d'ailleurs
pour la première fois si j'ai
l'Assemblée nationale corrigez-moi mais
vous étiez 6% 88
quand même on est d'accord que c'est pas
gagné mais on voit effectivement une
progression avec des retours en arrière
avec des retours
les petites du MLF à l'époque on a on
s'est tapé les gros problèmes
effectivement 67 il y a eu la
contraception car enfin était légalisée
en France en 67
on a quand même gagné mais avec beaucoup
beaucoup de mal merci Simone Veil la
bataille pour les végé pour l'avortement
en 75 mais toi c'était on a fait entrer
l'idée que le viol devait être jugé par
des cours d'assises comme crime et
n'étaient plus simplement délit tout ça
c'est bien en arrière là mais justement
c'était du lourd on a quand même nous en
France mais ailleurs c'est en même temps
c'est aux États-Unis c'était Hollande
c'était en Europe mais on a on a eu on
avait des sujets de
d'infrastructures de la société et qu'il
fallait débloquer grâce au ciel par
exemple le contrôle sur le contrôle sur
le droit ou non avoir des enfants le
contrôle de son corps c'est la grande
victoire quand même des années 70 on
avait pas avant maintenant le retour en
arrière je continue l'histoire des
femmes c'est toujours ça c'est toujours
deux pas en avant pas en arrière ça je
te disais Simone de Beauvoir déjà dans
le deuxième sexe et au retour en arrière
dès qu'il y a une crise et qui a des
quelque chose qui secoue la société
c'est le moment où on retourne en
arrière sur le droit des femmes mais je
peux en arrière oui mais en fait tout de
même
il y a eu des transition
en politique un point d'attention sur le
fait justement de du discours qui disent
il y a des progrès qui ont été faits
parce que ce discours abaisse la
combativité des femmes pour conquérir
leurs droits et par ces d'une parité
quantitative à une parité qualitative
reste un objectif d'abord parce que la
parité quantitative n'est pas
entièrement
acquises mais même je fais souvent
j'arrive à être un peu une mémé du
féminisme et vu mon grand âge et on
m'avait souvent dans des réunions d'élus
et je leur dis attention vous avez
l'impression parce que c'est vrai par
exemple dans des conseils départementaux
que le nouveau mode d'élection par
ticket homme femme ou femme homme plutôt
a permis désassembler paritaire alors
elles sont contentes le problème est il
est pas du tout réglé et justement je
fais intervenir les questions du même
splending et du même repting man
spléning avec une femme aimée une idée
intéressante une observation l'homme
s'en saisit sans citer ses sources et
pareil le même opting ou finalement on
interrompt les femmes beaucoup plus
rapidement confinement qu'on interrompt
les hommes et moi j'ai dit aux femmes je
vais jusqu'au bout et je dis à ces
femmes je dis vous allez chasser en
meute vous allez compter le temps de
parole si une femme on lui vole son idée
à vous de resituer de ressourcer ce que
ce que vient de dire votre collègue et
là ce combat là il ne peut se mener que
toutes ensemble il faut chasser en meute
c'est une expression vous utilisez
souvent lorsqu'il est question du combat
féministe
pourquoi l'égalité famome n'a pas été
obtenue parce que les hommes résistent
c'est pas par l'opération du
Saint-Esprit et il faut le poser et je
pense que c'est ça le débat aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il faut que mettre le doigt sur
le fait que les hommes résistent trop à
l'égalité et qu'en fait en faisant cela
ils assurent les conditions de leur
domination sur les femmes et que
aujourd'hui cela n'est plus acceptable
et je trouve que ce qui est actuellement
dans le débat politique en France c'est
précisément la resp des hommes dans
cette inégalité femme homme et justement
c'est pour ça que je trouve que la
phrase qui dit que les femmes de doivent
être des hommes comme les autres et bien
aujourd'hui n'est plus d'actualité parce
que nous l'idée n'est pas que nous
soyons des hommes comme les autres
l'idée que les hommes prennent
conscience de leur responsabilité dans
cette structure sociale patriarcale et
que du coup il fasse une forme de de pas
vers l'égalité et ça aujourd'hui et moi
je suis vraiment très choquée du fait
que après un mi tout mondial après un
mouvement qui a eu une ampleur quand
même d'une force incroyable et bien il y
a si peu de parole d'hommes pour dire
combien il n'était pas solidaire combien
il ne se reconnaissait pas dans ce qui
exercent des violences par exemple c'est
très rare de les entendre des hommes
dire ça et pourtant c'est absolument
essentiel grave en France je trouve chez
les femmes qui disent on se reconnaît
pas dans ce mouvement MiTo qui va être
loin il y a les hommes qui pour vous
mais tout ça a été un fait majeur un
marqueur
la première à écrire dessus en France
un peu tôt d'ailleurs et j'ai mis un
point d'interrogation et si c'était une
révolution parce que pour les diitrices
m'a dit c'est pas une révolution je n'en
sais rien mais je pense que c'est une
révolution donc on va mettre un point
d'interrogation maintenant c'est la
prise de parole donc qui a été une
révolution c'est la fin de la pour vous
le couvercle qui se soulève et je cite
et j'insiste vraiment là dessus
Françoise
Héritier la grande anthropologue était
vraiment qui a fait un travail fabuleux
sur le patriarcat dans toutes les
sociétés humaines et qui disait juste
avant sa mort mais toi a commencé elle a
tout de suite compris que c'était un
mouvement important et elle dit voilà
c'était l'outil qui manquait aux femmes
et parler mais elle savait pas qu'elle
était très très nombreuses à dire la
même chose à communiquer et l'internet
dit-elle à donner une diffusion à ce
mouvement qui existait mais les gens
savaient pas que les femmes pouvaient
vivre les mêmes expériences et ça
donnait un espèce de honte de choc
planétaire grâce à internet parce qu'on
n'aurait pas eu 8 ou aujourd'hui c'est
ça qui s'est passé avec cette question
centrale de la violence faite aux femmes
qu'elle soit sexuelles ou pas d'ailleurs
qui est arrivé comme ça au devant de la
scène à travers des affaires on peut
parler évidemment Weinstein évidemment
c'est la question du pouvoir surtout la
question des violences jusqu'à une
période assez récente a été marqué
socialement on estimait que la violence
c'était quelque chose de classe plus
modeste en fait la violence est un
phénomène général on sait que les
violences intraconjugales sont des
violences qui existent dans tous les
milieux tout ça a été tout ça a été
révélé que des professeurs d'universités
qui battent leur femme et bien ça existe
aussi bien sûr
je parle des violences intraconjugales
et il y avait évidemment les violences
intrafamiliales qui sont dénoncées de la
même façon mais vous avez raison je
parle évidemment des de tout cela et
c'est quelque chose qui vient tamponner
aussi quelque chose qui est au fond du
droit dans la dans notre pays
c'est-à-dire quand quelque sorte le
droit pour reprendre la formule de
combat terrestre s'arrête au seuil des
maisons et justement c'est un véritable
bouleversement culturel dans nos fonds
de mon juridiques de dire que le droit
doit rentrer dans la maison si on veut
combattre les violences doivent oui
franchir le seuil de la maison pardon si
on veut combattre ces violences moi j'ai
dit plusieurs fois que le privé était
politique qui est un slogan des années
70 et du MLF et alors ça a suscité mais
des tôles des tôlé mais vraiment où il y
a eu de grands éditorialistes donc
évidemment je dirais le nom par pudeur
mais qui disait
on va pas de regarder dans le lit des
personnes bien précisément c'est la
définition du viol conjugal c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait on a l'impression que ce qui
était dénoncé dans les années 70 comme
étant indispensable à l'égalité
c'est-à-dire d'aller voir dans le détail
où se loger l'inégalité et parmi les
lieux de l'inégalité parmi les lieux de
la domination il y a le foyer et ça je
crois qu'il faut qu'on le pose c'est à
dire que le foyer est un lieu de
violence c'est un lieu de domination et
donc ne pas aller regarder ne pas
autoriser la puissance publique à
protéger les femmes à l'intérieur de
leur foyer de même que les enfants
d'ailleurs quand il s'agit d'inceste et
bien c'est accepter la domination et
accepter cet ordre social et c'est en
cela que Me Too a quand même été une
révolution d'une ampleur sans doute dont
on ne mesure pas encore complètement les
conséquences même si ça ne permet
toujours pas d'aller à l'égalité mais
parce que pour la première fois il y a
eu ce mytho inceste par exemple qui pour
moi est au fondement mais vraiment
effectivement de la domination masculine
alors 5 ans après mis tout la société
française demeure très sexiste dans
toutes ses sphères voilà ça c'est la
conclusion du dernier rapport
du Haut Conseil à l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes que j'ai évoquées
lors de notre présentation
2500 personnes interrogées selon ce
rapport le monde du travail est perçu
comme particulièrement égalitaire ce 20%
des sondées considèrent que les femmes
et les hommes ils sont égaux en pratique
37% des femmes a fait en déjà avoir vécu
des discriminations sexistes dans leur
choix d'orientation professionnelle
100% des femmes ont vécu des
discriminations
dans un journal totalement macho à
l'époque mais c'est conclusions de ce
rapport français le nombre de plaintes
de viol qui n'aboutissent pas
quelles sont les derniers chiffres enfin
c'est de l'ordre de 10% qui aboutissent
contre 90% qui n'aboutissent pas les
lois sont là elles ne sont pas
appliquées pour l'état de raisons qu'on
connaît la résistance dont vous parlez
tout à l'heure des hommes en général
quand il y a encore il y a quelques
semaines une jeune femme va porter
plainte dans un commissariat on lui
demande comment était habillé
aujourd'hui mais où on est encore
gagné dans ce domaine et c'est vrai que
l'actualité récente nous là nous là nous
l'a appris s'il le fallait le droit à
l'IVG n'est plus un droit fédéral aux
États-Unis 14 États américains
aujourd'hui interdisent l'IVG depuis cet
arrêt de juin 2022 on pourrait citer
beaucoup d'autres choses des choses plus
people d'ailleurs le procès Johnny Deep
amberhead parce que là on a vu des
masculinistes monter au créneau ce qu'on
appelle d'ailleurs le le backlash c'est
un on peut produire ça pas peut-être
retour de bâton etc donc il y a ce que
vous disiez il y a une réunion une
réaction masculiniste
elle n'est pas qu'aux États-Unis quand
on voit les les réactions auxquelles je
suis par exemple moi confronté et la
violence avec que je subis en tant que
femme politique on se dit que les
masculinistes français agissent aussi en
meute exactement comme on peut le voir
aux États-Unis et par ailleurs je
rappelle quand même qu'il y a eu un
candidat à l'élection présidentielle qui
s'appelait Éric Zemmour qui
lui-même avait été
dénoncé par des femmes comme étant
possiblement agresseurs et en fait il
avait derrière lui toute une tout un
discours masculinisation assumé dans la
sphère politique donc en France aussi on
a ce on commence ce back clash et il ne
faut pas négliger la force de ces bacs
clashs et je pense que
le mouvement féministe est un mouvement
qui est tout à l'heure
qu'on va gagner avec les hommes et c'est
toujours cette ambiguïté
contre les hommes ou avec les hommes à
condition que les hommes à un moment
donné reconnaissent leur responsabilité
et check leurs privilèges et aujourd'hui
je pas de le faire et je pense que
précisément dans les années 70 il s'est
passé à un moment donné ce cette prise
de conscience par certains hommes de
détresse exactement et je crois que
aujourd'hui il résiste et il y a trop
peu d'hommes qui checkent leurs
privilèges et qui disent oui j'ai une
autre fois alors je vous donne la parole
après je voudrais vraiment
des contextes d'inquiétude des contextes
de nostalgie du passé qui joue
puissamment contre les femmes on voit
bien que c'était mieux avant alors on
nous le vend sur différentes choses
mais vous avez presque gagné la parce
que ça veut dire peut-être aussi que
qu'il y ait une réaction
à des contextes de guerre qu'on pensait
inimaginables face à une peur
irraisonnée des phénomènes migratoires
face aux bouleversement d'un certain
nombre de mécanismes économiques on est
en train de fantasmer un passé
totalement idéalisé je suis désolé j'ai
écrit l'histoire de ma grand-mère placée
domestique à 7 ans
ouvrière menant le combat pour l'égalité
des salaires dans son usine dans son
usine d'armement quand on me met un
passé mythique ou soi-disant c'était
formidable c'était mieux avant moi j'ai
envie de sortir le bazooka un
véritablement et tout ce contexte
évidemment il pousse devant lui cette
image patriarcale
fantasmée donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
vraiment pas baisser les bras et
abandonner et abandonner les armes ces
droits sont menacés de façon constante
et récurrente oui oui je voulais revenir
un peu ce que vous avez dit
moi je pense que les hommes ne vont pas
abandonner le pouvoir comme ça
spontanément ça n'existe pas dans
l'histoire on est d'accord là-dessus
mais moi ce qui avait écrit ils vont pas
vous dire prenez le pouvoir allez-y mais
pourquoi j'écris ce livre sur Youtube
parce que j'avais eu la tribune
de certaines personnalités sur la
liberté n'importe où on veut continuer à
faire passer les fesses dans le métro on
veut et continuer à être harcelé on aime
ça ça fait partie de l'érotisme du
romantisme français
ça m'amuse hors de voir parce que
justement quand vous avez une tribune
ciné que par des femmes qui disent on
veut continuer comme avant c'est
tellement contre-productif et c'est
vraiment le retour en arrière parce que
les il faut que les femmes arrêtent de
saigner systématiquement sur des
positions patriarcales c'est très bien
si les femmes étaient toutes féministes
on aurait déjà gagné puisque nous sommes
52% de cette population donc il y a pas
de doute
ce souvenir personnel quand je suis
arrivé à l'Assemblée nationale en 88
avec une seule idée de réputation de
féminisme j'ai une collec femme qui m'a
dit tu as tort d'autres battre d'abord
parce que le combat féministe discrédite
les femmes bon boum je pense en pleine
poivre et elle me dit tu sais c'est
beaucoup mieux qu'on soit très peu
nombreuse les caméras télévisions se
porteront plus facilement vers nous
[Musique]
quelques fois
c'est le mot de la fin
au tournant des années 2000 le mot
féministe était un mot une insulte on
n'osait pas dire je suis féministe et
que c'était extrêmement mal vu et là la
nouveauté c'est que maintenant on peut
de nouveau dire je suis féministe parce
que ça n'est pas ça n'est pas négatif
c'est devenu quand même quelque chose de
positif malgré les retours en arrière
donc on dire aujourd'hui je suis
féministe parce que je pense que tout
n'est pas gagné et que tout
effectivement revenir en arrière même si
ça revient pas exactement au Moyen-Âge
autant de nos grands-mères mais on peut
dire je suis féministe en se faire
insulter je sais pas si on peut le dire
aussi facilement
de mon expérience à moi je crois pas
qu'on puisse le dire si facilement et en
tous les cas nous sommes dans ces cas-là
la cible de violence encore beaucoup
trop importante et beaucoup trop tolérée
mais cette fois ça sera vraiment le mot
de la fin merci vraiment à toutes les
trois d'avoir participé à ce débat doc
aujourd'hui spécialement à vous Annette
livillard parce que c'est une partie de
votre histoire que nous a raconté le
documentaire que nous avions le plaisir
de présenter aujourd'hui dans cette
émission des Badoc vos réactions ça sera
sur hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter et je
compte sur vous vraiment pour répondre à
ce que seront ces réactions bien entendu
et elle risque d'être nombreuses à la
suite de cette émission merci à Selma
sali qui comme à l'accoutumée m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission puis moi je vous
retrouverai pour un prochain débat doc
et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]